quien en las afueras del palacio de
buckingham está lista toda la logística
para la que será una de las
celebraciones más grandes y emotivas que
ha visto el reino unido será también el
regreso de los eventos masivos de la
monarquía que no vemos desde la pandemia
del cobi 19 hace más de 2 años así que
aquí en las afueras del palacio se
esperan miles y miles de personas se
celebrarán los 70 años de isabel segunda
en el trono un récord personal que la
reina ha logrado su tatarabuela la reina
victoria estuvo 63 años y siete meses en
el trono hablamos con el experto
monarquista johnny diamond que nos
explica la importancia de esta
celebración del jubileo de platino y
en esto es un adiós este es el fin de
una era este su último viva la reina
seguirá siendo la reina de lo que se
cuenta con una buena salud pero sus
tareas oficiales van hacia el final esta
es la ocasión para agradecer celebrar y
recordar
[Música]
esta será una celebración de cuatro días
que arrancará con una de las más
coloridas trooping the colour que es una
ceremonia militar y también aérea en la
que participarán al menos
4.400 soldados
400 músicos y 200 caballos luego la
reina isabel saludar al público masivo
que seguramente estará aquí este jueves
desde su balcón también se ha aclarado
que la reina isabel no asistirá a todos
los eventos oficiales previstos porque
también se invitaba al público a que por
ejemplo el domingo hagan almuerzos
masivos para celebrar este momento tan
importante como ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas integrantes del público de todo
el mundo han llegado hasta este lugar
para poder ver a la reina isabel oa
cualquier integrante de la familia real
pero también desde que se habilitó este
espacio hace unas horas algunas personas
también de todo el mundo han llegado
acampar en las afueras del buckingham
palace esperando ver así sea por unos
segundos a una de las mujeres
probablemente la más famosa del mundo
fotografiada en nuestra historia
reciente así que acompáñenos aquí en
france24 en español para todos los
detalles en la celebración de este el
jubileo de platino de isabel segunda que
marca sus 70 años en el trono